This recipe has taken me
years to perfect, and
I think it's finally ready
to share with the world.
I just published it in my brand new
cookbook, Cooking with @walterlatimer.
[NOISE] So, what is a cookbook?
Well, a cookbook is a way
of documenting recipes,
it helps us make sense of all the tools
and ingredients in the kitchen.
Without this documentation, I might have
everything I need to make a delicious
meal but I wouldn't have any
idea how to put it all together.
Technical documentation exists for
a similar purpose.
To help us make sense of code.
Without it,
developers, you included, won't know
how to use other people's code.
They might not even know how to run it.
I read documentation for
all my projects, including this one.
In the instructor notes, you can find
a link to the Read Me I created for
this course.
There, you can find helpful
resources to help you along
as you work through this lesson.